the more financial technology is
advancing and payment solutions is
advancing it has a direct influence on
commerce
and on e-commerce
unfortunately however the mobile
interaction today is not very
comfortable i mean you know it's a small
screen
you don't see all the product
information so well sometimes you don't
feel comfortable to to make a purchase
on your mobile phone because of security
issues
but the more technology is advancing and
the more comfortable we we feel to to
make these decisions on this little
screen the more
commerce will happen on these screens
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders meet bianca
meger the co-ceo of shelfie.io
bianca brings more than 18 years of
experience to the metro one team with
extensive global experience in marketing
business development and sales she holds
a proven track record of establishing
data-driven customer-centric companies
over the past nine years bianca served
as chief marketing officer of various
leading tech companies in israel and was
nominated for the esteemed globe's 40
under 40 award
originally from africa bianca strongly
believes in the notion of it takes a
village and is convinced that
sophisticated technology unique business
models and a proactive regulatory
approach can make financial inclusion a
reality for all
the uncommed welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm very well thank you thanks for
having me i'm excited to be here thank
you very very much for joining me on on
another sort of 20 minute leaders i'm
excited to talk to you about your own
journey uh both from growing up in
africa and now in israel with a lot of
places in between but also holding a
critical positions in marketing and now
thinking a really in really interesting
ways about commerce mobile commerce a
customer-centric uh companies are now
running your own company and metro one
and also with the chelsea so a lot to
unpack in these 20 minutes and i think
that the best thing to do just to go all
the way to the beginning and go back to
your upbringing in namibia and and
what's happening there and how you grew
up in africa and and some of the values
that you've gained there and how they've
shaped who you are today
uh so i was raised on a farm in namibia
and
you know very exciting lots of adventure
lots of nature and
we were two girls no boys in the house
so i think we always we were raised with
the ability that girls can do everything
that boys can do and uh you know whether
it's hunting or pulling wires of the
fencing
so i grew up in a very equal household
where everyone basically had to jump in
and help and physical strength didn't
really matter when the task was there
you had to get it done
and i think it in growing up in africa
it teaches you a lot of things one of
them i would say is
resilience and independence and you know
when when you're living on a farm you
have no neighbors for about 20
kilometers around you so you have to
learn
to be self-reliant and if something's
wrong no one's going to come and fix it
you have to fix it yourself
so i think that's something that that's
very unique for africans i see a lot of
south african
uh people living in israel now also and
they have this you know can do attitude
and there we get our hands dirty and
jump in and so i think that's a cultural
thing as well
and i think another thing that that is
very important that we grew up with is
is being grateful
um you see very extremes in africa
extreme poverty and also extreme
richness and wealth and and i think this
puts things into perspective um so you
know that you shouldn't take anything
for granted
and you can be happy with very little so
i think this is one of the the core
values that that i take with me and i
really try to install it in my kids
today as well
even even in the office
that don't complain about this type of
coffee you know like uh be happy for for
what you have because not everyone has
it so i'd love to talk about these you
know these two values in the context of
your greater career so talking both
about the can do attitude and to you
know get stuff done and but also
practicing gratitude and and being
thankful for what we have so
let's start with the first one of the
can do attitude and getting stuff done
where where in your career whether now
or in previous positions
have this has this trait really come out
and been an added value for you in your
own career
so so i think
um
can do mean you know first of all it
gives me the ability to not be afraid to
try new things
um
and not only wait for someone smarter
than me so whenever i get a task or a
challenge you know from the start of my
career i would never say no to it i
would always you know try my best to to
do it to learn from it
um
which i think in many cases a lot of
people don't don't do that they say it's
not my department it's not my
responsibility you know give it to this
or this um so for me whenever someone
gave me something to do i i always tried
my best to do it
and and i always try to to help people
so
in my calendar for example even though i
have a lot of meetings i always tell the
team i'm always available
so whenever somebody needs help or
assistance or just you know a quick
question they should never feel like
they have to schedule time with me they
can just come and speak with me for two
three minutes we can resolve it and we
can work on it together
so i try to always be available also for
the team and together we can do it
better
so obviously i mean that that value of
you know being available and being
transparent and you know prioritizing
team members and and those small
conversations is great in practice on
theory but in practice you know you're
busy and you have things to do and all
those context switches sometimes can
actually harm your ability to get stuff
done so how do you balance and how do
you keep in check that you're not you
know over transparent and over available
where it comes at the expense of the
things that you have to do in your sort
of deep work time
so um
so first of all like you say it's a
balance
um and obviously sometimes you can say
to someone hey guys now i'm not
available or now is not a good time
um
but for example i'm someone that wakes
up at five o'clock in the morning
uh so i get you know my best emails my
best ideas between five to seven in the
morning
um and then also in the nights after
work time i come home i have a family
three kids uh but once they go to bed i
still make that time very focused to to
get the important stuff done
right so when it comes to practicing
gratitude in a high-paced world
especially in the you know in the
israeli ecosystem in the tech world and
you know sometimes i think it's hard and
we sort of forget you know to keep track
of where we are and to keep ourselves in
touch with you know what we have in the
privilege that we have so you know how
has your background changed the way that
you think about your daily work today
and sort of your interaction both with
your employees and perhaps your family
and so first of all i believe
that what we do
is very important
in the sense of you know growing up in
africa there's a lot of people that that
don't have for example i was in fintech
before i joined the chelsea and metro
one
uh serving populations that have no
access to banks no access to financing
uh so for me my work
in technology is really
you know
changing the lives of people that really
need technology for example being able
to open a money a wallet an e-wallet on
your phone
jumping over traditional uh technologies
to move to the mobile phone where we
really accelerate globalization and when
we speak about globalization i think
it's leveling the playing field for a
lot of people
you know the mobile phone for example
give people in in remote areas remote
cities villages access to speak to
people abroad access to to make an
income access to to get an education so
everything i do in the tech environment
i really try to choose
sectors where i know that it can make an
impact on people that that would not
have another way to to be in touch with
the with the world like we are here in
more developed countries so this is like
i would say like an inspiration in a way
and a motivation to to see it i love it
so walk me through your professional
career and you know both your entrance
into the marketing world and but then
transitioning more to leadership roles
within companies today running your own
company in the mobile commerce space
so so i was very fortunate my family we
had a lodge in africa so we're in the
tourism
so as a kid i always grew up with with
you know tourists and my parents had
their own safari company and my mom was
always you know doing marketing and we
had people and staying in our lodge so i
think i was very much exposed to an
international culture of service
and so i think from a young age i
understood the importance of of service
the importance of marketing and making
people aware of of a product or a
country and so i think that's kind of
where it piqued my interest to you know
it's amazing you know 20 30 years back
to be able to contact someone in germany
and tell them about your your country
and have them fly all the way over
based on a brochure it was it was
amazing for me that this could happen
i think that's kind of where where it
piqued my interest um
so naturally i just i just moved to this
field um
but the more i grew professionally and
the more exposure i had and and i was
very fortunate i worked with amazing
ceos and founders that really
i would say mentored me and and you know
taught me and and gave me that extra
side
of business and i think this enabled me
to make the transition from cmo to to
ceo
really understanding the financial side
the business side also i'm very
fortunate because my husband is a
businessman so
so i think with the support at home
where someone can challenge you but
still give you advice
it pushes you out of your comfort
comfort zone but it also gives you the
you know
like the confidence to to try something
new and to grow so so i i can say i was
very fortunate
also when you you know curiosity is very
important so um
the i i am very curious by nature
if you if you tell me anything i'll ask
why and how
um
and i think this is kind of also you
know i'm not afraid of taking risks i
believe you live once live it to the
fullest if you can move to any weird
country for two years go for it so i i
try to live life to the fullest so um
incredible and that goes for work so
mobile commerce
metro one
what is happening in the world today
what what is the opportunity that you've
identified with metro one
in the mobile commerce space
great so
today about 70
of all online purchases
comes via the mobile phone right and 54
of those of those sales are actually
done through the mobile phone
um so today we're all moving to our
phone we don't have time we're not
sitting next to our desktops we're you
know commuting we're traveling we're
between meetings so the mobile for sure
is a new technological stack that that
will change the way we do everything and
you can see it in all sectors
um
the more financial technology is
advancing and payment solutions is
advancing it has a direct influence on
commerce
and on e-commerce
unfortunately however the mobile
interaction today is not very
comfortable i mean you know it's a small
screen
you don't see all the product
information so well sometimes you don't
feel comfortable to to make a purchase
on your mobile phone because of security
issues
but the more technology is advancing and
the more comfortable we we feel to to
make these decisions on this little
screen
the more
commerce will happen on these screens
and what shelfie wants to do and what
we're what our vision is is to empower
retailers
to make this shift from
brick and motor stores or websites to
actually have their own mobile commerce
on on the mobile
on a screen that's very user friendly
it improves the the customers shopping
ability you know we developed our our
platform
based on the real estate of the phone
the screen of the phone we didn't
develop it on on the web or on a desktop
and then move it to the phone right we
decided okay this is the amount of space
we have how are we going to build the
best user interface and user experience
that can
make it convenient for the customers to
shop
but also give value to the retailer
because now the retailer has a way of
you know staying engaged with his
customers they have a way of
communicating with their customers and
and they can also you know show products
and and personalize the shopping
experience so when i know that that my
client is always shopping this type of
brand
i know what they like i can recommend
some other stuff and and really make it
a one journey whether you're on the on
the e-commerce side or on your mobile
platform
but give them the ability to really sell
properly through the mobile phone and
and grow their business
why is it so hard today so you know why
obviously you know it's a it's that
that's the reality and that's where
we're moving and you know generation z
are i believe the heaviest purchaser
purchasers today on e-commerce and
mobile commerce and so what what is
happening you know in terms of the
brick-and-mortar stores or the retailers
that are trying to make this transition
what are the biggest pain points that
you've identified that is inhibiting
them from just doing it independently on
their own
so so first of all
you know their focus is on their you
know selling goods or whether it's
fashion or whether it's groceries right
that's their level of expertise yeah
but you have to move to the digital
world
and instead of bringing huge development
teams you know we speak with a lot of uh
retailers big grocery shops and and the
owner says to me bianca i'm not a
developer i don't want to understand
how complicated it is to integrate with
my erp systems
um so what we're trying to do is to take
that complicated development out
of the picture and really give um a
proper solution to retailers that they
can literally just drag and drop
whatever they need
uh our our system connects directly to
their erp system or their e-commerce
platform so whether it's shopify or
woocommerce or magento
we pull all the data from their systems
and they can launch the application in a
matter of an hour or two and so we
really try to make it very simple um
because yes it's it's complicated and
it's scary you know the second i'm not a
technical person at all
uh so i don't want to struggle for three
weeks you know how to put this code here
and how to
deal with this api
so we're really trying to build a system
that is very user-friendly hassle-free
no coding required and and this will
help business owners to really focus on
their core business which is growing
their retail shop engaging with their
customers and giving good customer
service so is the vision for you know
one day in the next few years to be in a
position where metro one is an enabler
for you know many brick and mortar
stores to transition to mobile commerce
and sort of be their backbone their
their front end and back end to
to leverage on their speciality which is
actually producing and selling the goods
while your specialty is providing the
technological and enabler to get that in
front of their customers is that the
grand vision
correct yes so that's the grand vision
so we really enable retailers to collect
all their customer data on multiple
channels
and then enable them to grow enable them
to offer personalized services to that
specific customer based on ai and
machine learning and enable them you
know to really track and monitor
where the customer is what they like to
buy
um and then you really create this
unique experience for their customers
bianca take me back to
you know your own upbringing again and
and i'd love to know you know beyond the
values that you've gained um and the
understanding of gratitude and the can
do attitude what is the you know what
what are some things that left you
fascinated in your day to day or really
sparked your curiosity
hmm so i think
so so i think that the fact that again
people globalization
used to be very limited based on you
know if an airplane can fly you or
whether you can make a phone call
um and again the fact that you know you
can see this plane landing on the middle
of nowhere yeah and have people come you
know without fear
uh and and have a new experience is
amazing
and and then also meeting different
people i think was uh was very
intriguing for me
uh as a child and
yes i think i think this whole
tourism side of our family really made a
huge impact on me and it showed how big
the world was
uh even though now it sometimes feels
very small
and
but yeah i think
you know in working i grew up for
example in in namibia which was that
time a very
apartheid era you know i was born and
raised in this in this period and seeing
someone like for example nelson mandela
that could
go through all of this prosecution and
you know have immense personal loss
but still be able to forgive the people
that caused them the suffering and
you know be so visionary and make
everyone feel special
this had a huge impact on me so you know
even today no matter where i am whether
you know i'm in a hotel and it's a
cleaner or whether i'm meeting a very
important ceo i i really always try to
look at the person for the person
and try to understand that person
because
you know that's our your client in the
end of the day and in the end we all
have the same needs we all want the same
things we all have the same aspirations
no matter where we are in the world so
human behavior is is very similar
um
and i think if you can understand that
you can you know create products that
really really make a change and really
make a difference in people so so these
are the things that really intrigue me
and that i like to look at um
you know even even i look at
i take my kids to a village in africa
with with him buzz you know they wear
traditional clothing they have no
schools
and and they just connect and they have
the same excitement about things and or
whether we are not flying to europe and
and they meet kids there so so seeing
this is the common thread that runs
through civilization is very intriguing
for me i love it i love it and if you
have to think of a few words that
would describe you
um bianca whether it's you know you from
africa are you from israel now what are
a few words that would describe you
so so i'm very curious very curious you
know my nickname as a child was ah the y
is starting again
and even today my husband when someone
starts to talk uh you know my eye starts
moving he's like okay we're on boarding
the y train again like uh so so i love
to ask questions
everything is interesting for me
depending on which you know low tech
high tech it doesn't matter
uh i think i i think i'm fun i try to be
fun at least i think life is too short
uh
too short whatever i do i try to really
enjoy the moment and i i never pass on
anything you know if you're standing
next to the beach and it's freezing and
someone says let's jump in
i will jump in no matter
how cold incredible
and another another word really i think
uh
again the the being grateful i i really
don't take anything for granted and i
think in covert
it was a huge i think awakening for
people because i i was grateful for the
big stuff you know a lot of people lost
their jobs a lot of people especially in
africa it was you know they didn't have
the infrastructure like israel or the
support from the government
so i was you know grateful for having
stability in a country like israel for
example but also small things like you
know hearing your kids laugh or not
hearing airplanes over the sky and
seeing a blue sky and being able to sit
outside in the sun and work for a change
um
so i think those are the words that that
would describe me in a nutshell
bianca thank you very very much this was
great i love talking about your
upbringing and how that translates to
today and the appreciation for what you
had then and how that gives you a
different perspective on on you know
both your you as a leader but also you
as a part of the tech world and then
impact maker today with metro one and
mobile commerce so thank you for the
time and stay safe and stay healthy
great thank you so much and good luck
with your shows i love it thank you have
a great evening